حسيت بالهزه فكان انه بطيئه انه ما كنت
يعني متوقعه يسبب هالدمار
كنت احسنه تترك امي
كانت دايخه كل ما بتنطخ بتقول لي عيفني
قلتها
نقول عنقول لحرمتي لينا مثلا يا رب تكون
حلم تكون حلم عم نحلم ونفيق منها مو
معقوله مثلا هيك نموت بهالعذاب
خالد
خالد فتون كرم غيث تيم سنه
اذان المغرب
هذا بكل ما بيجي لهم يا ابن اخوي كل ما
بيجي
والسلام عليكم يا ابو كرم كيفك يا ابو كرم
ما حدا ابدلة
امتحانات اللي تاجلوا
فما مثل انه قبل كنت افكر اني والله اجيب
معدلات
وفكر اني بس اتخرج افتح مخبره وعيش حياتي
وحقق احلامي
فهلا من الظروف كلها يعني انه خلص تحطم كل
شيء يعني البيت راح والدراسه حتى الدراسه
ما عاد مثل قبل يعني كنت
اتوقع اني اجيب احسن من هيك علامات وهيك
يعني حتى العلامات تغيرت وما ضل مكان ادرس
حتى فيه الولاد راحوا الحرمه راحت والبيت
راحت وكل شيء راح ما كاني كاني انا شاب
اعزب وما عندي اي شيء بهالدنيا
[موسيقى]
شلون بدي ازبط الخيمه بدها شيء بطانيه
قرات اللي ناكل فيها المهم الله حاليا عم
فاجر بالخيمه ولا قدام ايش ما في تفكير
بالمره الا قدامنا
بعدين فوتوني على الاسعاف لايدي بعد كم
اسبوع قالوا لي بدنا دم خضروني وقطعوها
كل يوم على العمليه نفخوا لي ايدي ورجلي
بس كنت عم بتوجع حلو والله
ضليت على هالحاله من يوم الزلزال وانا
لحالك كل يوم تبديل
وقالوا لي يمكن خمسه او اربعه
ركبوا لي ما بعرف شو العلاج اللي راح
يعالجونيه وشلون راح يعالجوني
كنا موجودين في بيتنا احلامنا حياتنا كل
شي كان مامن ما كنا رضيانين هلا صار حلم
يعني هيك هدول كل الايام نتمنى لو يرجع
واحد ما عم يفكر بالمستقبل بدك تشتغل
تشتغل وتجمع مثل ما قال الاخر 50 ثانيه كل
شيء راح شو بدك تشتغل بتمنى بس عشان اطراف
عشان اقدر امشي واساعد امي
وابوي واختي
واحاول اشتغل
واشوف مستقبلي
الايام تفعل ما تشاؤوا وطب نفسا اذا حكم
القضاء ولا تدع لحادثه الليالي انا ومالك
الدنيا
وارضى الله واسعه ولكن اذا نزل الخطا ضاق
الفضعوا الحمد لله